all right I'm gonna start welcome to the
closing speech of the NDC this year
we're gonna try to sum up everything no
this is the low-power cellular for the
IOT I'm going to talk about some
interesting new opportunities that are
coming along from new technology start
brought into cellular but come from the
low power low throughput aspects that
are needed for for cellular connecting
everything in the IOT so Who am I
my background is in technologies that I
started doing software and then I kind
of wondered how these things work and I
ended up starting to work on a hardware
design the microcontroller core that was
used for for processing on radios that
led me into working on these wireless
system on chips I've been doing that
ever since really and working on the
architecture of these processing and
wireless communication silicon chips
that go into the IOT and consequently
also working on the software that runs
on them both from a stack perspective
but also the application and I also do a
lot of work on snow shoveling of course
that's mandatory in Norway so my name is
Peter and I work for Nordic
semiconductor and we make among other
things these wireless ssese so cellular
IOT was a matter I think one of the
reasons so there are always new
standards that come about in the
wireless space one of the things that
makes the cellular IOT especially
interesting is that sort of the network
is already deployed and then they come
up with the standard so the 4G routers
base stations are already out there
they're the deployed out we have great
coverage in most countries in the world
and then along comes a standard that
makes it possible through a software
upgrade to make these base stations talk
to low-power IOT devices so that's what
makes it interesting is not a slow
rollout it's quite fast
and from a couple of years ago there
being nothing till now it's kind of
everywhere it's a it's an interesting
journey and that makes it very
interesting to look at and something
that can scale pretty quickly and
there's some interesting applications
too so this is about you know removing
the Gateway because the Gateway as a
sort of a privately owned unit in a
network is just a nuisance it's
something you need to have there in
order to make everything work and
actually talk to the cloud but it
doesn't really do anything for your
product which is your IOT device that
you're shipping out to the customer and
provides the service so what you
actually want to do is go directly from
your IOT device to the cloud to someone
else's computer which is the cloud and I
count the cellular network in the cloud
because it's someone else's computer
someone else's problem to make sure it
works and it's professionally managed
and it's always there and it's had a
great great coverage in the industrial
world so and as we all know budget wise
I think we just made this whole solution
a lot cheaper we removed the
thousand-dollar iPhone right so what can
we use it for a big one is asset
tracking there's I mean you go on Google
for everything now on search you expect
to find everything there and it's kind
of amazing that you can't really find
your thing song Google so if you lost
something you can't find it there but
that's about to change
you should be able to go on you know
Google or whatever all their platform
you have for cloud and find your things
and the reason why this is a good fit
for asset tracking is because you can
get the location GPS signals coming in
to sometimes the same piece of silicon
that runs the cellular network you can
get the condition by interfacing to a
sense
like temperature humidity measuring
shock for example you can also
communicate to subunits using a
short-range network if you have you know
a container like this you may have
pallets insider or boxes that you track
with smaller units like Bluetooth Low
Energy or similar and I think the
appetite for especially for companies
and industrial companies to know at any
given time where all their things are
the things that they own and they may be
valuable and may be very expensive that
people running around to look for them
that is that is something that are is
slowly being acknowledged more and more
the fact that you can now do it using
the same cellular network that you're
using with your phone and have devices
you know small is this one running on a
battery tag on to it stick there stays
there for 2-3 years without changing the
battery and you know at any given point
in time where it is and what condition
it's in you have health care and that's
a completely different dynamic but
that's really an aspect where you don't
want the patient to be the network
operator what I mean by that is it's
extremely important to reduce the amount
of time that someone needs to spend in
the healthcare institution like a
hospital so if you can send them home a
day early a couple of weeks early even
bime doing that safely by making sure
that you can still monitor their health
condition when they're at home
that can save the society a lot of money
and that makes for healthier and more
happy people in patients so the problem
with that is if you send them home and
say hey connect this thing to your Wi-Fi
network and we should be able to monitor
you as long as you stay in your house it
doesn't work right I have to punch in
the SSID somehow and the chance of it
failing is just extremely high the
things with a cellular network when the
patient leaves the hospital the things
already working it's connected when they
are out on the street it's connected
when they get home still connected and
the patient doesn't have to think about
it or do anything
now that's extremely important wearables
there are scenarios I mean everyone has
these smartwatches these days and
connect them through their phone etc but
there are cases where you kind of want
to leave the phone at home and actually
not carrying the phone anywhere it's
something that some people appreciate as
well especially in the sport and fitness
and sort of security and safety there
are aspects of well that you may want to
be able to send a message to the world
but you don't really want your you know
Facebook on one of you when you're out
running so that is an interesting aspect
may be more useful overall for society
it's the metering in countries like
Norway and most of the developed world
and actually now in some parts of the
underdeveloped world as well they're
deploying meters that and an
infrastructure for meters that are
automatically read and the
infrastructure is generally sub 1
gigahertz proprietary networks that they
put up masts they put up gateways they
communicate with a proprietary network
to the stations that they can see and
the meters that they can see and then
they communicate that back to the cloud
through the cellular network that can be
simplified a lot by just connecting
every single meter to the cellular
network now that the cellular devices
have gotten smaller less complex draw
less power cost less and a grids great
coverage and scalability the LTE
networks are really fantastic remember
in the old days when you know if there
were a lot of people around maybe you
couldn't even place a call and figure
out at a concert or something you
couldn't do anything but with LTE
there's like almost limitless how many
nodes you can have in a certain area by
well-managed network planning and in
smart city cities can save a lot
optimizing garbage truck routes by
knowing where and the city the bins are
full so if they if you can at any given
point in time feed an algorithm
all the information about where the
trash is you can optimize the rots quite
significantly I have less trucks the
streetlights can be on only when they
need to you can have share bikes that
you can find easily on the map on your
phone go pick one up take it to wherever
you want drop it off again and someone
else can find it there smart parking
let's load in the city so there's a big
problem with people driving around the
block several times to find the parking
spot increases traffic a lot in in
annoyance as well and smart parking is
about being able to reserve a spot for
you near where you're going and knowing
that it's there and available when you
get there using sensors in the ground
mostly and there are all these other
ones like predictive maintenance
products as a service you know placing a
product in someone's home or business
and not charging for the product itself
but charging for the service of using it
making sure that you maintain that
connection but what we're really hoping
is that the biggest applications for
this and the things that we really
changed thinks is not on this slide it's
something that we haven't even thought
about yet but someone else working on in
the garage somewhere so where do we
place the low-power cellular IOT in the
landscape of different low-power wide
area network technologies so I like to
categorize it into low power and not so
low power standards and then by
throughput so if you look at this is
your traditional cellular that using
your phone like LT category 6 or 9 not
at all low power but very high
throughput fantastic efficiency but it
doesn't really work for devices with low
throughput and they have two G which was
a great idea like 25 years ago but it's
very high power and not very spectrum
efficient and then comes env IOT and L
TM is two standard
they're a bit different I'll talk about
why how they're different but they both
basically serve to replace different
aspects of the 2g functionality while
doing it out a very low power and being
future-proof as we all know to G's going
away three G's going away even faster
than that the spectrum that is used for
those technologies is too valuable to
use for old technologies like 2g and 3G
so I think in most regions of the world
2g will be gone by 2025 and few placing
your products in the field now that's
supposed to last for 10 years simple
math that won't work so I have to come
up with something else
so one alternative is the proprietary
low-power wide area networks like cig
Fox and Laura and some of the other ones
that I was shown earlier today as well
the sort of to compare the two
there's licensed and unlicensed bands
Cellular's and licensed bands which
means the cellular operator paid
probably a lot of money to be able to be
the only one to operate in that band
which means there's no interference from
anything else operating there and when
they then have an advanced protocol like
LTE on top to make sure that the
individual devices that operate in the
network don't step on each other's toes
then you have what is a great scaleable
solution with good quality of service
security is built into LT from day one
we all know the sim card right that's
what it is it's an authentication and
encryption piece of hardware that makes
sure that you know when you connect to
the network it knows that it's you it
also knows the secret key so you can
talk without being monitored and having
the security onboard means you can
connect also directly to your cloud
service so you don't have to go through
some intermediate server that someone
else owns you can connect your iot end
device directly to the cloud
and use technologies like TLS to secure
that end-to-end I'll talk more about
that too and then another one that's
interesting and and for those of you
caught your Kim's talk earlier that's
there are no limiting regulatory
restrictions on output power in the
licensed bands the licensed bands you
can use the use very high output power
if you want and and in cellular LTE you
can use up to 23 DBM which means you can
transmit over very long distances and
you can transmit as much as you want
within what cellular operator will allow
you but for example under Etsy for the
sub one gigahertz eight six eight
megahertz band if you are not in a
licensed band but then that public band
then you are allowed less than one
percent duty cycle on transmit which
means that you're basically staying
quiet most of the time to be compliant
with the regulatory standards so I
mentioned both l TM and narrowband IOT
so what's the difference it has to do
with link budget translates in through
range traded off with throughput so the
l TM is higher throughput up to 375
kilobits per second but only about four
times the range of standard LTE whereas
MB IOT is like sixty kilobits per second
and can get you up to seven times the
range of standard LTE and that's
probably the biggest difference and then
we get into mobility which means as you
moving down the highway for example on
the truck
can you elegantly jump from one base
station to the next and know which
frequencies you should go to etc and
being handed over
and you can do that now with LT M and B
IOT there's a future version that will
support that but doesn't support that
yet can you do roaming going across
country borders and to a different
network on a different operator and
still have it work we're so spoiled with
that on our phones now right we enjoyed
get off the plane anywhere and turn it
on it works but it's not automatic
and it doesn't work yet friend B IOT
they have made it work for LT m because
it's more similar to standard LT so I
think at a high level if you have a
stationary node that's sitting there
let's say a smart meter for example
talking to the same base station day in
and day out with very limited data then
MB IOT is probably the right choice it
has longer range and slightly less
overhead on transmission so it's lower
power if you have something that's
moving around that you're tracking the
Maven cross borders then LT M is
probably the right choice so I pull this
from the G SMS or website yesterday this
is the current national deployment map
for LT m and narrowband IOT they update
this very frequently they're about 60
networks available globally today with
LT m or narrowband IOT most of them are
regional like Sweden is not asked
backwards as it may look on this map
they do actually have quite a few places
where there is coverage but they haven't
deployed the entire country yet and so
this is you know as time moves on we'll
see a lot more of these regions becoming
purple and you know obviously they
started in the Netherlands where you
only need like one base station to cover
the entire country if you have it high
up on a mast but Norway is actually an
interesting one because that it's not a
very simple geographic region
and they still make it work very well so
there's coverage all over the place
around so what are these devices that
make up the IOT for cellular how do they
look so essentially they consist of a
few components that are common to most
wireless technologies so you have your
battery or your power source you have
some kind of sensor that's enter enter
facing with with the real world
reading temperature humidity accelerant
acceleration etc you have your SIM card
or UICC as its called
if you get very technical that provides
stealth indication on to the network and
then you have the antenna and and inside
of here you have a processing unit a
[Music]
modem for the rest'
RF and some front-end components like
amplification and things to make sure
that you get the good signal on the from
a software perspective what's most
interesting is this MCU that's sitting
on here that is what processes the data
that's coming in through the sensor and
decides what to send over-the-air to
communicate back to the cloud and and
that's where I would say the most of the
magic happens when you decide to define
a new device if you're making a new
product you'll make some new hardware
sure but that's not really where the
magic happens it happens in here when
you decide what is the device actually
supposed to be doing what kind of data
will it send and how does a process that
before it gets sent from my perspective
working on designing these chips the
real magic happens here in the in the
modem there are millions of lines of
code to make sure that the interaction
between different devices in the
cellular and
work is constructive and that they don't
step on each other's toes and you get
all the throughput and quality service
that you need so from an application
perspective what are you looking at
right you you put your application on
top your interfaces to the network you
can choose from any of the standard
protocols
I'm qtt it's very popular very simple
co-op HTTP all pretty well-known they
use an API talk to the TCP UDP stack and
encrypt with TLS or DTLS as appropriate
through ipv4 or ipv6 depending on
network support and then down to the
layers of the LT stack into the physical
layer that actually transmits the data
to the base station so and the choice of
these application level protocols you
have MQTT which is an ascii based
machine-to-machine protocol it uses a
publish/subscribe model so you can
publish to a certain topic you ever
subscribe to the topic and receive the
messages typically runs over TCP and
then uses TLS encryption now this is a
pretty heavy protocol for a constrained
device which is why they come up came up
with a constrained application protocol
as an alternative and that uses a rest
model like HTTP like get put post delete
it uses a very compressed four byte
binary header and transmits over UDP so
you don't have the overhead of tio TCP
and use the detail s which is
significantly lighter than TLS most
silicon has acceleration for the
encryption so it's not really a big
concern from a power perspective this
encryption if you do it
sequentially processing wise it can draw
a lot of power over time but most
silicon has acceleration that does the
encryption in parallel using Hart
dedicated Hardware blocks but it's still
as a ads protocol overhead to use TLS
over detail s so so why not always use
co-op right because I mean mqtt is a lot
simpler and you can put anything in
there like it's really easy to put like
Jason payload and so MQTT packet for
example and get that directly to the
cloud and it's easy it's easy and TCP
gets through all the firewalls or all at
least compared to you to be which you
can run into trouble sometimes with some
of the firewalls so guess those are the
main considerations there and then on
top of that you have your tie-in I would
say with the with the cellular standard
so with MQTT generally it's used with
LTE em and co-op is generally used with
NB IOT so when you find reference
designs for example typically that's
what you'll find but there's no real
reason not to you can mix and match
there's no so I want to talk a little
bit about the basics of LTE how do you
actually get a device onto the network
because it's not your network when it's
your network it's easy when it's someone
else's network it's still a bit more
complicated I'm gonna walk you through
that so here's your device over here
you've got yours
you know wireless SOC or antenna your
SIM card and then you have two base
stations nearby transmitting the master
information block contains information
about what kind of features it supports
obviously you can read the signal
strength from it and in this case the
device will scan and find both of these
and it will see that this one is closer
has a higher signal strength I'll
connect to that one supports all the
features I want
so it sends an attached request that
attached requests close to the mobility
management entity and then it sends out
an authentication request to the device
say ok so who are you and that
information goes back through the
mobility management entity and all the
way back to your home subscriber service
now I've drawn this in that's a very
separate entity because it very well may
be in the completely different part of
the world say you're roaming into some
area in the US for example the mobility
management entities right there with the
cellular core network of the by operator
that iran but this one is like Telenoid
Italia in Norway that needs to be
contacted to make sure that this SIM
card is actually enabled with a
subscription that allows it to roam here
and then once that's been confirmed then
you get a scheduler that schedules your
time on the air that I'll see to be up
through to a serving gateway and this is
in the core network of the cellular
operator and that's serving gateway or
APN allows you to get out to the
Internet to your cloud and then you have
your data flow from device through the
oh sorry device through the serving
gateway into the cloud simplified that
looks a little bit like this so you have
reseller the core network all the way to
the cloud and you can imagine this is
now like from an IOT perspective
connectivity wise it's problem solved
right you have your device you have your
cloud connection you can get anything
uploaded downloaded you're done all you
need to do now is write the application
there and you'll need to write the
application on the cloud and the
connectivity is no longer a problem but
of course you do need to consider
security so some of its given like I
said Security's kind of built into LT
which is great but so I tried to draw a
tunnel here but so the SIM card
authentication and encryption actually
allows you a really good encryption
over-the-air
so that gets you into the cellular corn
network but you know you're gonna go all
the way to the cloud which means you
need another layer of encryption because
this stuff's going over the Internet
once you pass through the APM you're on
the world wide web right so you need
clothes off entik a ssin and encryption
from your cloud to make sure that from
an application perspective it's talking
to the right device it's getting the
data and no one else is being able to
see it so it needs to be encrypted
actually twice but then n B IOT
especially this is a kind of popular
model this you have your device it
doesn't do any encryption other than the
encryption that's assisted by the SIM
card and it talks to a server inside the
core network this may be an ask F or a
different type of server but it talks to
server that sits inside of the operators
network behind all the firewalls right
and then you from your cloud you can get
a token to go use an API that extracts
data from this server inside the cloud
so then you're actually only encrypting
our data once and the encryption to your
cloud happens in the second stage when
it leaves the core network of the
operator so kind of the problem I would
say with this model is that right here
this data is unencrypted and it's your
data but that's not your server and you
can argue that the cloud is always
someone else's machine right but it's
still you know something that needs to
be taken into account what if you're
roaming what if this is in some
operators network that you don't even
trust so there are there potential
issues here but that's there's a simple
model and then there's this and this has
less overhead this is why it's popular
and will be the right solution for some
but won't be the right solution for for
all applications
and then flexibility and upgrades and
this kind of goes for all wireless
technologies and the IOT but especially
important to think about when you deploy
something in the wide area network
because of its nature the units are
either far away or mobile not easy to
get to after you actually deployed them
so if you have 10 years of battery life
as a goal you know when do you find the
bug
probably going to find most of the bugs
in the first six months probably gonna
have an appetite to fix those bugs and
send out a new firmware image and when
will we find the security vulnerability
hopefully become before it becomes a
real problem right but you may see the
vulnerability may want to fix it maybe
put a new version of the stock into the
device that should be done and when
would you want to upgrade your
performance or features like if you
deploy something and it's not really
competitive after a few years and you're
providing it as a service then it's not
good to be stuck with the kind of
functionality of the device that's in
the field you may like Tesla is doing
you may sell a car with all the promises
of those great features that it's going
to have sometime in the future you sell
the hardware and then you start pushing
updates to enable some of the features
in the future so the other aspect is
when we're talking about machine
learning and adaptive algorithms and
there's a lot of ways where this
actually relies on updating the code
that runs on the end device so yeah you
need to you know use data crunching in
the cloud to improve the algorithms and
then you need to push the algorithms
back down into the devices so that they
can make intelligent local decisions
I'll talk more about that but basically
what we have is a new standard
well say new is fierce old but from the
Open Mobile Alliance they've decided
designed the LW m2m runs on top of coop
and it
methods for transmitting new signed and
encrypted firmware images down to the
device and signed and encrypted is of
course very important because you want
to be absolutely sure that the device
will only accept the firmware image that
you want it to have that no one else can
actually update that but once you have
the cloud connection this can be the
same cloud as you use for your data and
processing an application or it can be a
different cloud provider that you use
only for firmware updates and and and
that would go through a different
channel so I'm going to talk a little
bit about embedded development cassettes
because said the magic happens when you
implement the application on top of the
stock inside of the IOT device so some
of the challenges compared to computers
the target device doesn't have a screen
or keyboard how do you di get how do you
step through the code and understand
where it goes wrong because it will it's
a big challenge show that restrict the
data in program memory these things are
they don't have more memory than they
absolutely need to and the reason for
that is you know one megabyte of flash
to or fro may not mean a whole lot ah no
you know when you're buying a computer
but if you're gonna build you know a
hundred million toothbrushes with IOT
inside once you start multiplying that
cost of maybe 20 cents for a megabyte of
flash you multiply that by 100 million
and all of a sudden you are really eager
to reduce the amount of flash to ease
and then there's a limited energy source
available generally these devices
supposedly are mobile and lasts for a
long time so you can't just waste energy
everything you need to do needs to be
optimized
and you know you don't have cooling
problems like you're doing a data center
for cloud you you actually will run out
of battery way before you have a cooling
problem so the embedded development how
do you do this so you write your code on
your computer and your favorite editor
use some kind of compiler to compile the
code into binary assembly code for the
oops sorry for the target device that
runs the code and the application on the
embedded IT device and then you use USB
to push this into the device through an
emulator that translates this into a
serial communication that the target
understands and is able to receive and
program itself and then once the target
is programmed you can start to run it
and then the emulator locally can halt
it can inspect regions of memory can get
trace data out from program flow for
example and use that to display it back
on the ID of the of the PC so this is
how even if you have no keyboard or or
screen on your actual end device you use
this little emulator to be able to use
your computer ask the keyboard and
screen for for debugging your in your
i/o TN device so edge computing this is
a it's one of those topics that gets
talked about a lot but I want to present
my view other people have different
views on this but you know feel free to
voice your opinion later but this the
way we see it is radio transfers sending
data actually costs a lot of energy and
when you're in cellular doesn't only
cost energy it costs a subscription fee
I think you have a data plan you don't
want to use it all up or have to
increase the data plan just because you
were
wasting how much data you're sending so
you should send information and not data
I'll give an example of what I mean by
that but that kind of falls apart when
you were trying to learn something and
improve your product or your Al Gore Al
Gurren because the only actually meet
the data you don't need the information
and then so when something interesting
happens you need to send the data anyway
so I'll walk you through an example try
and illustrate what I mean by that but
first I want to just show why I mean
what wise processing data is
significantly cheaper than sending it so
this is an example from cellular IOT if
you're processing data on a typical at
cortex m-class processor you're
averaging around three milliamps of
current over let's say three
milliseconds that should be ample time
to do some simple processing on a couple
of hundred bytes if you want to transmit
a couple of hundred bytes over the air
through your cellular networks instead
of processing it locally you're just
sending it to the cloud then you're
gonna average about 150 milliamps over
that's pretty much same period of time
so this is why it's extremely important
to transmit as little as possible really
distill the data down to information in
the i/o TN device before you start
sending so here's an example so I pulled
it off of this thing which has an
accelerometer on it and basically what
we're looking at here is a time graph
with the x y&z axis measuring basically
gravity that provides a continuous
stream of three times 16-bit values and
it does so every 100 milliseconds so you
have the x y&z axis 16-bit value on that
and it transmits it ten times a second
and what you see is something happens
here
obviously triggering some kind of
response from this device
it was probably sleeping but then this
happens and then you get a response from
from the processor wakes up starts to
trying to digest what actually did
happen and you if you do look for the
information you can see that what
actually is happening here is this
device is flipping over changing which
axis is up and it's then after that
laying flat this isn't and this is an
event so instead of sending what is then
you know if you take this this whole
image maybe it's like a hundred bytes of
data you can actually get that all that
information into one byte of data saying
it flipped over to the left or to the
right or and that's now laying still
that can be transmitted with one byte of
data instead of sending all 100 but then
something interesting happens sitting
there asked should and it wakes up
because something's happening on the
accelerometer but it can't understand
what happened that doesn't look anything
like the graph before the algorithm
doesn't detect what is actually the
event so what do you do you send the
full data set that you have stored in
your buffer take it send it to the cloud
you analyzed by correlation to other
known information that you hopefully
have in your cloud let's say this is
sitting my desk in my office well you'd
probably find if you had access to the
to the access control system is that at
the very same time that this peak came
out someone actually opened the door and
the just by the door closing that was
enough to trigger the little event and
that's the kind of magic you can do in
the cloud you can't do that locally on
the device but what you can do is you
can understand that and then you can
make an algorithm
that says hey if you see this thing this
is probably the door closing so we'll
categories it as dot and then take
appropriate action locally if necessary
maybe turning off the lights something
like that so this is why it's very
important to when there's something that
happens that you know
yeah machine learning you talk about the
the confidence level of of the algorithm
defecting actually what are this this is
when you have zero confidence the
algorithm is stupid doesn't understand
much but when it understands nothing it
should just send the full data set up
and then I want to talk a little bit
about expanding is the cellular IOT is a
useful for a lot of different notes but
there are certainly some nodes that are
too small like you can't fit a cellular
modem and the batteries and everything
that's needed from an antenna
perspective to deal with the sub one
gigahertz and then you may want to have
smaller nodes cheaper nodes notes that
use less power and lasts for longer you
can do that and then you build this sort
of hybrid network and a good example of
this is the asset tracking again going
back to that container where you have
boxes inside so you track the container
with cellular and then you gather up the
information using a local network to
understand what actually is in that
container that's all of these different
boxes and then you transmit that back
through the cloud over the cellular
connection and the boxes leave the
container go into different container
that gets tracked over there continue to
track them but they don't all need to
have a cellular connection so you can
mix and match a little bit and make a
hybrid network that meets the
requirements for power and costs even if
it still stays fully connected to to the
internet most of the time okay so this
is my last slide I want to show you a
little bit of summary things that I want
you to take away from this
so cellular IOT it gives a bit of low
power cloud access to things I mean
there's coverage virtually anywhere in
most countries now that are developed
big cities at least and over time it
will be almost everywhere and then you
can get a connectivity for low-power
devices wherever you go as a rule of
thumb LTM is for mobile devices with
sort of medium data requirements where
as MB IOT is for stationary devices with
low data requirements the throughput and
you should send information in the IOT
not data except when something
interesting happens I mean you need to
send the full data set and of course I
found the solution to my snow shoveling
problem and then I'm gonna reach out to
these guys but I found left-hand
robotics comm make this robotic snow
plow that just travels around and passes
information up to the cloud about where
it is and how deep the snow is in the
conditions etc and you don't have to
lift a finger you can sit anywhere you
want the monitor thing driving around
your neighborhood cleaning everything up
so that's the future and it uses
cellular IOT so thank you
any questions or you can just come up
yeah I always have a roofie yeah it's
the this little thing that's the
processing the cellular modem GPS and
all the memory and crystals and power
management and things that are needed
for that so essentially you just need
the antenna that thing in the SIM card
the SIM cards from Talia and that ten
would works as well yeah and get cloud
connectivity of anywhere you go and you
can operate on the on the battery and we
have ways to sort of measure the power
consumption over time so you can track
what - battery life time you can expect
out of it yeah it's it's exciting now
it's we design it in the Nordics I would
say it's a lot of the cellular modem
guys are from Finland ex nokia guys no
surprise the low-power I'm see you guys
are all inter online and then we
manufacture it in Taiwan and China and
Malaysia
yeah for we I mean we yeah we sell
mostly Bluetooth low-energy chips today
and we ship about 1 million pieces a day
so so this is gonna be at least as high
volume and stop eventually
yeah so I mean the the three living in
my on batteries they're not picked on
random that's that's actually a pretty
good setup for a cellular node of this
type - yeah three thousand seven hundred
milliamp hours battery for something
that sir just stays connected and
doesn't send that much data it's very
reasonable for ten years
and really again fully depends on how
you do your application if you decide to
send everything up all the time and
battery's gonna be gone in a week almost
doesn't matter which battery you put on
and that's why it's very important to
sort of facilitate local processing and
also facilitate making sure that you
don't let the modem use up all the
resources that's that's tricky because
your phone is designed very differently
it's if you don't get it get the
connection it will try and try and try
and try until the battery's dead
and if you're making a smart meter for
example you can't do that you need to
make sure that if it doesn't manage to
send anything for a week that's fine
but it shouldn't drain the battery that
was dimension to be there for twenty
years in that week just because they
couldn't connect so very different
problems to handle but the sort of
predictability of battery life is
something that's very extremely
important to handle in the cellular IOT
otherwise any calculation you make will
just be wasted
yeah
now that's a good question no but they
actually would then we're talking the
tens of nano amps to store the data per
let's say 32 kilobytes of data so that
doesn't drain the battery too much it's
much more significant that when you do
when you then decide to send you send
with a lot less overhead for example in
LTM if you send 150 bytes or 10 times
100 and 50 bytes actually doesn't matter
they make that big of a difference so if
you manage to buffer up a lot of data
and store it locally and the timing of
getting it to the cloud is not that
important you can send data much more
efficiently than if you do just one byte
at a time
that's just because of the cellular
network again lots of devices you have
to kind of say okay I'm gonna talk now
and you get a slot and you had any
transmit and if you transmit a lot or a
little a little at that time doesn't
really matter that much not like in ble
or other sort of short-range protocols
yes yeah so LTM an Arab and IOT will
actually both be part of 5g so 5 G's
about three different things one it's
the low latency one it's the massive IOT
and the other one is very high
throughput and these are three totally
different vectors and the massive IOT
part of 5g is actually LTM and Arab and
IOT as well than the other standards
it's gonna evolve getting new features
better performance and all this stuff
but it's it's the same standards that
are being carried forward both of them
so not just one so that's the that was
an important decision that was made this
year actually
I think there will be a lot around
location assistance there are nice
features already today and cellular to
triangulate time difference of arrival
between different base stations of known
position so you can get a rough estimate
of where you are even when you don't
have GPS coverage like indoors
so I think that's one of the things
we're looking forward in then obviously
improvements on efficiency being able to
reduce overhead transmit more data in a
shorter amount of time I think that's
the apart from that there are just
physical limits to what you can do and
the spectral efficiency spectrum
efficiency of the modulations that are
used is like nearing the theoretical
limits so I don't think we'll see very
significant improvements on that but
it's more yeah where the protocol that
they're I think will will see
significant advances
so let's see for embedded programming
there are you know there were some talks
or even this week about using JavaScript
for example micro Python there are
certainly opportunities to work at a
higher abstraction layer but it all gets
translated into C and for debugging sort
of the the the the IDs that are in
operation today generally have this
assembly language and machine code
translation to see they've got that down
so you can step through lines of C code
and for the most of the time you can see
the variable C the value of the variable
that you created but once you take it up
another level of abstraction to like
JavaScript or Python it gets translated
again which means you probably lose even
more of the information that you use for
debugging so the variables that you
defined originally may not even be there
anymore and and that's that makes
debugging with these higher level
abstraction language is significantly
different on these embedded devices so I
would expect C is probably for the let's
say professional developer I would think
plain C is going to be the preferred
language for at least another five years
or so till they got this figured out
yeah
yeah I would say it's certainly like for
encryption compression very
computationally heavy algorithms even
like doing FFTs on understanding if
there's this peak or spike and the value
when the the sort of inner loops of
these algorithms you can with generally
you can save something by writing them
in assembly but on the other hand if you
are a really good friend of your
preferred C compiler you can also
generally make it produce the assembly
code that you want by writing the C code
intelligently so there's I would say in
a like professional use there are very
few times when we see that assembly code
is used for for optimization of code and
and and I generally find that a good C
compiler is significantly smarter than
me in optimizations I think of things
that I didn't think of so there's I
think we're at that level now yes
yeah that's an excellent question I'm
not I think it's because I listed
actually three different protocols
Bluetooth SIG being thread and there's
actually a difference and actually
exactly that aspect because in Bluetooth
Low Energy it doesn't it has very strict
time slots that Billy is a synchronized
protocol so the central and ble that is
sitting on the Gateway can actually go
to sleep in between events whereas in
sig be and actually in thread the
gateway device coordinator and the
signal network for example needs to stay
awake and in receive the entire time
because these are asynchronous protocols
so it never knows when the next packet
is going to come in from the end nodes
so then it needs to stay in receive mode
dross around five milliamps doing that
and that's continuous whereas in be lead
can go to sleep draw like to my cramps
one my cramp and still wake up at the
exactly right time to take the next
connection event okay I think we're out
of questions thank you have a great
weekend